Wow. I hate how our society has brainwashed women
into saying crap like this.
Staying home with your children is not always a privilege.
If you read my comments, you will see how many women say,
I struggled my butt off, but I was able to stay home with my children.
I just made the necessary sacrifices.
I understand not everybody can do that, honey.
But let me tell you, if I could divulge every secret
and every sacrifice my husband and I made
so that I could stay home with my first born,
you would be shocked. I won't get into the nitty gritty details.
Diddy be Diddy. I digress.
We lived in the smallest home.
I co slept with my baby. It was one bedroom.
I had one bathroom. I couldn't even go in there to use the bathroom
when my child was sleeping.
So I used alternative measure.
We didn't go on vacations.
I stopped getting my hair done.
I stopped doing my nail. I clipped coupons.
My husband shot an Elk, which we lived off for the last year and a half.
I had small side hustles I did on the side
just so I could have a little extra money for baby toys,
whatever we needed. We got every single ounce of clothing
that my child has had since the beginning of his life
from a very common thrift store here in Texas called Just Between
Friends. Were beautiful,
well loved clothes. And my son Never looked untaken care of.
I breastfed as much as I could
because people have no idea the cost of daycare
and not breastfeeding your own child.
When I did try to go to work,
all I ended up doing was paying to go to work because I.
To pay my niece to come over.
And then I would run from the office as much as I could
just to be with him.
And I would try not to leave him for longer than two hours at a time
because I didn't even know all this information.
It just felt wrong in my gut.
But do not sit here and say
it is a pleasure or a luxury for most people.
Sorry. Not a pleasure,
a privilege. Mom brain.
Plus the amount of stress and pressure that my husband had to provide,
which, by the Grace of god,
we are doing so amazing right now.
I don't regret any moment or any sacrifice
or any coupon clipped
that I had to do in order to make sure I stayed with my baby,
because it is the smallest chapter in their entire lives.
And as far as your guilt, I am so sorry that you feel guilty.
But what I have Learned, even from my own personal experience,
is that guilt and shame is your internal compass saying
maybe something was off. Now,
there are some women that have no husbands,
no father in the picture, no ability to work from Home,
no educational background,
no family that they live with.
Um,
a lot of military families that I'm familiar with here are like that
because they have no family here.
But at the end of the day,
I will not stop sharing this information
because it makes some people uncomfortable.
Because, like I said before,
if I can spare a mama
whose gut is telling her to stay home and make the sacrifices,
because it's not always a privilege,
as you state, I'm going to keep speaking for the betterment of her,
her children, and our society.
Because if you're wondering how we got here,
it's because we have had generations that started us with this.
Starting at the baby boomers,
with mothers leaving us at home,
going to work. We divided the nuclear family.
We taught women that men are trash.
Women are taught to go work for big corporate companies,
also run by men, and that sacrifices do not need to happen
in order to rear their children the way they need to.
I felt guilty, too,
babe, after my first kid,
and I still did as much as I could to be with him.
That is why I speak on this,
because nobody understands how detrimental our culture has made it
for stay at home moms, for women in general,
for mothers, for children,
dropping them off to the government,
paying daycare workers to take care of our children.
Because I know some women who literally don't
Wanna stop going on vacation.
They don't wanna stop getting their hair and nails done.
They don't wanna clip coupons.
They wanna shop at the most expensive stores.
And they will work so they can afford those luxuries
and choose not to stay with home with their children.
So, no,
I'm not shaming anyone. I am just giving information so that we know.
Because our life here in America is about informed consent.
And we have not been informed on this.
In fact, there's a lot of bogus studies saying quite the opposite.
So, no,
I will talk about this. God,
if people just knew some of the crazy stuff I did to stay at home,
you would never, ever say that I was privileged.
But last thing I will say is
I was blessed enough and smart enough to pick a really good man
who supported us through all of it.
But like most people say, you need two incomes to run a home now.
So obviously we had to make some type type of sacrifice.
Not just some, like a lot. And I don't regret it.